[Music]
hi i'm christopher hine
and this week we're talking about a
timmy in aikido so what is it timmy the
classic strikes niketo what does that
mean
and how does aikido look at a timmy
timmy is a japanese word that means to
strike the body to hit something
to hit the body with something and that
a timmy could be
a hand or a foot but it could also be an
arrow or anything else right so from the
root
so to to hit the body to strike the body
and the meat means the body that you're
hitting
so what are those in aikido last time we
talked about showman and yokoman and i
showed you how those are perfectly
normal strikes that people use
constantly all the time in in modern
life today we're going to talk about ski
and what ski is and ski is often
misunderstood
as a punch when in fact it's just a
thrust and the way that we do
uh the thrust in aikido also looks
really silly and goofy and i'm gonna
explain to you today
why that position exists and and why we
do need to train against a strike that's
done like that
because of systematically the way we
look at it so the ski in aikido has a
very particular reason that it's done
that way
and we're going to talk about that in
this video i'm going to get josh over
here and we're going to go to work josh
okay so this week we're talking about a
timmy and aikido and that's aikido
strikes
last video we talked about showman yokom
and gyaku yokoman and what those are and
and how they might arise and hopefully
by the end of that video you're like oh
those strikes are actually pretty
sensible and they're not as weird as i
thought
um and the reason for that is because
we're always trying to make a distance
where
a boxing situation is not going to
happen right so so understand if
josh and i were going to box right so if
we were both getting ready to box so
we're here in a hands up situation we're
going to box
okay we're going to set a distance where
we can hit each other right
now that distance is basically mutual
meaning if josh throws that punch out
and i return this shot
we're basically hitting each other about
the same set of distances right
so that means i can't really get too far
away from him
if i want to hit him back so if what i
think i'm doing to josh is trying to hit
him back
then i can never get that far out of
distance right so
um the the strikes in aikido don't come
from these boxing
ideas because if i square up on josh and
i'm gonna box josh josh's immediate
ideas to do that okay
now once he does that i can't box him
from here right i can't box him so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to
position in right so i'm going to come
in now what josh is going to do is this
again
because he doesn't want to box me back
so meaning every time i try to box josh
josh is going to move further away from
me right so i come here to box josh josh
moves
so i can't be in a boxing stance so i'm
gonna leave my boxing stance to get over
here to him
and i could i could stand my boxing
stance that's just slow but i'm gonna
leave my boxing stance i'm gonna come
over to this guy
and he's gonna redistance again and this
is what's going to be going on over and
over now what will this draw me into if
i want to hit him
well it will draw me into me running and
trying to throw large
shots at this guy right if i had a
weapon it would be even better right so
if i had a knife on my hand and this
guy's trying to distance
well i'm going to get this fool like
this right i'm going gonna really run in
there and get him that's what i'm
looking for is really coming after this
guy
swinging big shots to get him so we
don't have
boxing distance strikes because we're
not gonna box him back so because i
don't want to box this guy and i'm gonna
take a step every time
then we're not in a boxing range which
means we're always going to be pulled
out of that boxing range
for extended strikes now this leads us
to why
ski in aikido looks the same looks the
way it looks
so in aikido we have skeet and people
often think that's a punch
it means punch or something right ski
simply means thrust so let's have josh
show you what a ski looks like so josh
is here
he throws a ski looks like this that's a
that's a ski right now it looks
goofy right if you've seen any boxing
art you're like oh geez
why would anyone ever throw a punch like
that it's slow and it's big and it's
going to take all day to get there it's
no good right so
let's let me see that just so josh is
stand square for me okay so i'm here
like this so this is ski
bang i come in i'm throwing this big
shot now why would i ever throw a big
shot like that
okay i would rather throw a shot here
right so if we're in distance like this
this is where i want to throw my shots
okay however every time i set to that
distance
josh is going to move out of the
distance right so i came in more josh
would move out more we don't have enough
camera space to do that right now but
that's what would be happening right so
he's moving out
so it's going to draw me into taking big
shots in at this guy
now if i had a knife what would that
situation be like right
so let's say i'm trying to get josh with
this knife right so i'm trying to get
him
now he's trying to distance but let's
say i'm faster than him
he's going to use his hands to suppress
right so like this he's going to get
some kind of suppression up
and then he's going to try to move to
better position so he's going to move in
here moves he throwing me or eating so
that's what he's trying to do now i
won't like it when he does that so i'll
have an action
so when we're here and he tries to get
to that position i might do something
like this
okay now i got into this position now if
josh wants to fight with me
he's losing it's a losing proposition so
josh instantly as an aikido practitioner
knows to back out of this distance
so he's going to go right about there
can't come this way for me a little
sweet stay in frame
all right so here he's right here now
what am i going to do in a rash decision
to attack him i'm going to go like this
like this so understand we're here and
he's got me suppressed and i decide to
defend my weapon like this and he
distance
i'm going to come out far to get him so
i'm going to reach far to get him
now that's a dangerous shot for him if
he's not ready for not ready for to
defend against that kind of strike
he might very well get caught so that's
the way he's going to deal with it now
people say
oh well someone's attacking with a knife
they're using short strikes right let me
show you what i mean
so we're in distance what should i be
doing i should be doing this this is how
i should be working that knife
working in close to this guy and really
trying to work my knife
josh is always trying to get distance
he's always trying to pull further and
further and further away
if we're in close he's going to try to
suppress and get positioned so that's
always the game josh is playing
so a very real threat he might be facing
is he jumps out of distance and i lunge
in to get him so he's training himself
to deal with me
lunging in him so that's why ski looks
the way it looks now that's not to say
it's going to be easy to do this stuff
that's what the training's for the
training in iq is teach yourself to
position
but you shouldn't be worrying about
spending a lot of time learning to box
with someone that's another system if
you want to learn to box
go to a boxing gym and that's great like
i recommend that i learn to box boxing's
really fantastic thing there's lots of
great ways to study boxing
but when you're looking at aikido you're
looking at how to make distance and
because you're looking at how to make
distance you're going to be seeing a
different set of strikes than you would
in a boxing gym
so when looking at the aikido strikes
you have to understand the idea of the
distancing
and how that plays into what we're doing
i'm christopher hines thanks for
watching